Get a quote today.
>> Tucker: AMBASSADOR JOHN
BOLTON, A FREQUENT FIXTURE ON
FOX WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE
YESTERDAY FOR A PERSONAL MEETING
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
A LOT OF REPORTS SAY HE COULD BE
THE NEXT NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
THE FOLLOWING QUESTION IS MORE
RELEVANT THAN EVER.
WHAT DOES AMBASSADOR BOLTON
THINK IS THE GREATEST THREAT TO
AMERICA TODAY?
HE JOINS US NOW.
IT FEELS LIKE WE'RE MOVING IN
SLOW MOTION TOWARDS A CONFLICT
WITH IRAN AND RUSSIA IN SYRIA.
DO YOU THINK WE ARE?
>> I THINK THAT'S ONE
POSSIBILITY.
THE IRANIANS HAVE CLEARLY GAINED
WHAT THEY PLAN TO DO AFTER THE
DEFEAT OF THE ISIS TERRITORIAL
DEFEAT OF THE ISIS TERRITORIAL T
DEFEAT OF THE ISIS TERRITORIAL R
DEFEAT OF THE ISIS TERRITORIAL I
DEFEAT OF THE ISIS TERRITORIAL O
DEFEAT OF THE ISIS TERRITORIAL Y
DEFEAT OF THE ISIS TERRITORIAL .
THEY WERE THINKING OF IT WHEN
OUR STRATEGISTS WERE NOT AND WE
ARE NOW SUFFERING THE
CONSEQUENCES WITH IRAN LITERALLY
ON ISRAEL'S BORDER FLYING DRONES
INTO ISRAELI AIRSPACE.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE MOST
DANGEROUS ASPECT OF THE
MIDDLE EAST, I STILL THINK IT'S
IRAN'S SUPPORT FOR TERRORISM AND
ITS CONTINUED EFFORT TO GET
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> Tucker: IN RETROSPECT, WE
CAN CONCEDE, THERE HAVEN'T BEEN
ANY IRAN SPONSORED TERROR
ATTACKS MUST COUNTRY THAT I'M
AWARE OF IN THE LAST 25 YEARS.
THERE HAVE BEEN MANY, MANY
SPONSORED BY SAUDI ARABIA AND
THE GULF STATES.
WHY SHOULD WE SEE IRAN AS OUR
PRIMARY THREAT?
>> BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN THE
WORLD'S CENTRAL BANKERS OF
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM FUNDING.
THEY PROVIDE ARMS AS THEY DO TO
HAMAS IN THE GAZA STRIP.
IT'S THEIR SUPPORT FOR TERRORISM
GENERALLY THAT SHOULD CONCERN
US, NOT NECESSARILY SPECIFIC
ATTACKS IN THE UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: IN ORDER TO COMMIT
AMERICAN TROOPS IN THE BILLIONS
IT TAKES, WOULDN'T YOU WANT TO
GO AFTER THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ATTACKING US HERE FIRST?
>> NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT
COMMITTING MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
TROOPS.
WHAT WE HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT, I
THINK MOST IMPORTANTLY IS THE
THREAT OF NORTH KOREA'S NUCLEAR
WEAPONS PROGRAM WHICH IS MORE
ADVANCED THAN IRAN'S.
IT ALL TIES TOGETHER IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN REPORTS
RECENTLY OF A U.N. INSPECTORS
STUDY OF NORTH KOREA SELLING
CHEMICAL WEAPONS TO SYRIA.
LIKELY FINANCED BY IRAN.
THERE IS A PALPABLE THREAT TO
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION,
SOMETHING THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACTED AGAINST EARLY IN HIS TERM
THAT THE NORTH KOREANS HAVE
BROUGHT INTO THE MIDDLE EAST
WITH IRAN'S PARTICIPATION.
>> Tucker: IN 2015, YOU WROTE
A PIECE FOR "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SAYING WE OUGHT TO BOMB IRAN IN
ORDER TO STOP THEIR WEAPONS.
SPEAK OUT THAT'S NOT QUITE WHAT
I SAID.
THAT'S WHAT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HEADLINE SAID.
>> Tucker: THAT'S HOW I READ
IT.
SPEAK OUT WRITE THE HEADLINES.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT THE ONLY
TIME YOU CALLED ON CONFLICT WITH
IRAN.
>> WITH ISRAEL ITSELF, AND THE
UNITED STATES, WE ARE IN A
BETTER PLACE TODAY FOR ISRAEL
HAVING BOUND SADDAM HUSSEIN'S
NUCLEAR REACTOR IN 1981 AND FOR
ISRAEL HAVING BOMBED THE REACTOR
THAT NORTH KOREA WAS BUILDING IN
SYRIA IN SEPTEMBER 2007.
>> Tucker: IN THE FIRST TWO
COUNTRIES, WE'VE HAD REGIME
CHANGE.
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
TO ARGUE THAT, WE'VE HAD TO
ARGUE, LET'S TAKE A ROCK TO
BEGIN WITH, WE HAVE TO ARGUE
THAT EVERYTHING THAT FOLLOWED
FROM THE FALL OF SADDAM HUSSEIN
FOLLOWED INEVITABLY, SOLELY, AND
UNALTERABLY FROM THE DECISION TO
OVERTHROW IT AND THAT'S NOT
TRUE.
>> Tucker: I WOULD NEVER ARGUE
THAT.
YOU JUST SENT IRAN AS A SINGLE
GREATEST THREAT TO US AND TO
THAT REGION.
I THINK YOU'LL CONCEDE THAT
SADDAM WAS THE GREATEST
COUNTERBALANCE TO IRAN AND THEY
WERE EMPOWERED BY HIS FALL.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY IF YOU
THINK IRAN IS THE REAL THREAT,
WE HAVE TO DEFEND THAT DECISION.
>> I THINK YOUR ANALYSIS IS
SIMPLEMINDED, FRANKLY.
THE IRANIAN THREAT WHICH STEMS
FROM THE REVOLUTION OF 79 WAS
UNDERWAY QUITE APART FROM WHAT
SADDAM HUSSEIN WAS DOING.
THE IRANIANS TRIED TO GET
NUCLEAR WEAPONS FOR 25 YEARS.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T THINK HE
MADE IRAN STRONGER?
>> AT THE FALL OF SADDAM DID NOT
MAKE A ROUND STRONGER.
WHAT MADE AROUND STRONGER
ULTIMATELY WAS THE WITHDRAWAL OF
AMERICAN FORCES IN 2011.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE THE ONLY
PERSON I'VE MET WHO THINKS THAT.
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY IF YOU COULD
SUM UP ONE LESSON FROM WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN IRAQ?
>> THE OVERTHROW OF SADDAM
HUSSEIN, THAT MILITARY ACTION
WAS A RESOUNDING SUCCESS.
I THINK THE MISTAKES THAT WERE
MADE SUBSEQUENTLY, SETTING UP
THE COALITION PROVISIONAL
AUTHORITY AND OTHERS THAT